hi everybody I'm Jeff Allen or from
Ubisoft Montreal and welcome to this
commented walkthrough video for Honor's
story campaign is a tale of warriors
that takes place at a turning point in
the age-old war amongst our three
factions you will play as Knights
Vikings and samurai as they're fighting
for the survival of their people against
each other and against the evil warlord
apollyon legendary heroes massive
battles and epic duels welcome to the
world of for on earth
now what you're going to see next is a
Viking mission from halfway through the
game's story campaign we hope you'll
enjoy it
apollyon swore had taken us to the edge
of extinction but that Raider reminded
us of who
we would raid
but not apollyon not yet but they knew
we were coming
okay
this part of the game takes place in the
Maya the land of the samurai broken by
their war against the Poli on the
Vikings are starving but they've heard
the samurai are wealthy and have riches
hidden in their legendary fortress so
they decide to raid and plunder
through the guides
the gates of that fortress hadn't worked
for a century all we had to do was get
through them we're playing as the Raider
who's the main Viking hero from the
campaign fearless and full of Rage is
the essence of the Viking warrior
yeah
now we're facing a shoe goki a massive
samurai warrior with a cannibal as a
weapon he's kind of slow but you better
be dodging his attacks because if he
hits you and gets you really hard
here again is our unique combat system
the art of battle which lets you
experience melee combat as though you
have a weapon in your hand once our
enemy is locked we can switch between
left right and top stances by using the
right stick on the controller from there
we want to match our enemy's stance when
he's attacking to block him and attack
from an angle he's not defending that
wall was the only way forward
ROK's troposphere
go lead the climb
one warrior made it to the top one would
be enough
in for honor your weapon is not the only
way to get rid of your opponent you can
use the environment to your advantage
our troops are still stuck outside the
gates of the great fortress and we need
to find a way to let them in
we're dying down there
yeah that's an unlucky guy one hint is
enough to kill your enemy when striking
from above Tata get that gate open
the Raider got us inside that fort walk
anyway
their commander was legendary among his
people plant hours
we managed to get our army into the
fortress now it's time to reunite with
them for the final assault
seems that our fellow Vikings are
storming the bridge so we'll take an
alternate path we we just needed to push
son about Annika
Savitz summer musubi they were hawkish
de my fortress is lost my soldiers
slaughtered soon i will join them
you opened the gate now you will pay
time to fight Subaru he's one of the
many bosses that you'll encounter in for
honors campaign
here we've entered into revenge mode you
can trigger this special mode once
you've blocked or taken enough damage
revenge mode will bring you stronger
defense and you will deal more damages
that Raider showed us what Viking fury
could do
the great raid they would call it and it
had begun alright guys thanks for
watching we hope you've enjoyed this
sneak peek afore honors story campaign
also playable in two-player co-op online
and split-screen
now the game comes out on February 14th
2017 on ps4 Xbox one and PC and during
our alpha phase we're gonna need your
help so go over to for honor game calm
and sign up today we'll see you soon on
the battlefield